all right I was not planning to stream
but here I am joining the daily rapid
arena with just over 21 minutes left
playing Yvonne chick 79 I mean I might
only have time for one game this game
goes the whole distance he's rated 1337
so hopefully it won't go the full
distance and we have a Philidor defense
what do I play against a field order you
play a number of things I think I'll
start with Knight c3 very likely I'll
play d4 next f5 I have some big memory
of one game where my opponent played at
five and I think I played d4 let's play
d4 I'm just relying on memory and this
is a principle thing to do when you're
ahead and development of my opponent's
playing quickly
can I take takes takes Queen h5 King d7
what is this opening it takes e5 me
black doesn't have to take g7 I can also
just take back I mean this looks very
reasonable then maybe d5 could come
takes takes Queen h5 here takes takes
looks good for whites
I have to look this up afterwards
let's take I mean I can also after a d5
I could play Knight g3 also looks very
playable Bishop g4 Wow so developing a
piece finally my first four moves for
pawn moves from black I mean this looks
good I might be taking my opponent too
seriously I mean this might be complete
garbage for black I just take and this
could just be a good position it takes
back we trade Queens I win the pawn if
Bishop takes Queen takes pawn takes that
also looks fun so d5 so I'll be up a
pawn now Bishop g5 is a move by g3 is
logical Knight c3 is playable 93
and it might be a battle around whether
or not I can hang on to the pawn let's
play c3 play quick move if Bishop a5 I
triple fork all the bishops and the King
coordinator is still possible Bach would
have to play Bishop d7 or Queen d7 I
like this position the opening threw me
off a little bit
hello to people in the chat good to see
you people I try and stay focused on the
game on h3
I mean h3 it maybe seems most normal I'm
tempted to play this and see if the
bishop see if he sees the bishops
attacked maybe there's some logic queen
here at Bishop g7 I moved back attack
both pawns Bishop c6 594 yeah let's have
some fun if Queen d7 I think I'm happy
to trade Queens I'm already happy being
up a pawn now I'm even more happy
winning the bishop yeah I think what
happened my opponent probably knew like
the first maybe three or four moves like
new this is an opening that just went
wrong went terribly wrong somewhere okay
g6 now it's a matter of converting
quickly and getting another game in this
looks fun but Knight f6 happens
h4 looks fun I mean black is very much
tied down and this is a type of position
okay Queen takes g6 type of position
it's easy for blacks to self-destruct
only one legal move and then I'll play
you six and I'll meet on f7 most likely
or there'll be some resignation
so what's gonna happen oh checkmates
okay 14 moves I was a quick game
analysis board actually had this in a
tournament once where I think my
opponent had played f4 was an f4 I I
remember this because I had like this as
famous tactic where I think I played
Bishop c4 my have wanted played Bishop
g4 and then I took and it was such a
feel-good moment in my life because
after it takes Bishop c4 Bishop f7 kini
795 mates now this didn't happen the
game but I was able to unleash Knight
takes e5 and eventually win the game so
yeah I think this is a dubious opening
but maybe it's playable remembering
maybe Knight g5 can also be playable
masters database let's start with any
masters playlist mmm a handful but yeah
d4 wait what so there's one game after
f5 but 18 games after a d4 so there is
probably some transposition so how does
this usually come about different move
order so white plays Knight c3 here so
takes takes yeah I was singing d5 is
probably the best like d5 Knight g3 I
was going to play Knight here looks
aggressive probably not great then a fee
for 95 yeah this looked very reasonable
Locke has these pawns but I've had three
ideas I have the Knights developed okay
well hello two people I'm gonna try and
play one more game maybe I'll put that
on youtube beating a dubious pressure
off and 14 moves
if you're watching on YouTube in the
future I hope you had fun watching that
and I'll see you in the future